okay boomer all the way all the way
which youtuber could I beat in a fight
back in the ancient time people would
challenge each other as a duel and my
second-in-command is with me today
cinnamon toast can you can fight command
that's right this is what people did
back in the day any argument you
challenge for a duel this kind of looks
like me and markiplier actually yeah
that kind of does and that is you cast
me watching yeah you know if I fail to
do all that means you got a stand-in for
me ah what we both got a DA we can't hit
the mark well that's the point okay so I
made I made this chart it's been well
yeah yep so these are all the people
that I'm gonna fight to do that
geez that's some wanna bright there oh
I'm on there oh go ahead just put me all
the way to the left will come to your
turn you're obviously last can come on
yeah I got to be because the trail is
the story on the same command you're the
man in the end right yeah sounds gonna
go it's how it's got to go anyway first
what I want to know I want to know you
may be bad to say this but like what
what kind of fight is just like like a
duel like he'd go out into the field
like punch each other or you guys what
are you doing you're right
their role is simple I am in a
self-defense scenario for legal reasons
they're attacking to you of course they
are attacking me I did nothing wrong but
I am forced to defend myself okay right
right whereas I have the rightful choice
as to go all the way you know all the
way to execute or if I want to just
immobilize this is the immobilize square
so I brought little so brought you in
here for a second reason Ken okay was
that just so you can confirm if what I'm
saying is true oh you need a second
opinion
yeah okay yes right I got you don't
worry okay but I don't have your back at
the same time mmm
mm okay legal wordings here I'll let you
I'll let you play this out whichever the
way you want okay first one it's got to
be Logan Paul Gabby Logan Pau he's got
the oh my god
Oh actually sorry before we start we
need to fill in my strengths
Oh your strengths you gotta make your
character hard right like select your
fighter weaknesses 9 you already filled
out I I mean there was more than are you
talking about all right some more than
average okay yeah you're very you're
very tall you're at least least taller
than Morsy is and very tall all right so
I'm not the most built person in the
world fine I'll admit but good slender
body yeah you can move you can wheat and
dodge and weave yeah and dodge and weave
you quick quick all right
well I goes with the slender body yeah
yeah you quick quick witted maybe no
yeah I like that
like the Cerebral Assassin you get in
their heads
you make them overthinking attack that's
right thank you all right weakness can
we agree on no no I can't agree on that
we have like you already filled out none
as your weakness
I can't tell people my wig fits the
maybe you're overconfident maybe you're
just a little overconfident yeah all
right maybe we'll put maybe maybe can't
type a little over confident
just little x okay okay all right now we
have that filled out let's get into the
duel yeah Logan Paul here's bigger than
me I'll give him that
maybe tiny bit stronger than me I'll
give him a little bit maybe which kind
of puts him over here and then you
realize you know would Logan Paul kill
me he has an affinity for dead people so
absolutely he would kill me and then
film it too on top of that oh that's the
thing that I think will make me
persevere I will be in last stand like
Call of Duty I will be in fetal position
Yeah right right I'll be like oh god no
I can't let Logan Paul kill me that
would be the worst thing possible I
think I heard somewhere
has like 15% of his testicles or
something like that I have no idea I
don't know any more about testicles and
I do yeah I do because I started my
course I said fetal position grab those
last 50 percent and he drops down to
fair fight ah airFiber
probably it's hard for my called the
boss and traitors and all that stuff
he's doing do you'd have you'd have that
advantage right oh that's right I think
that actually puts me there thank you I
mean you'd be on the ground he'd be
going for the kill shot that he's also
like you know turn into a screw making
sure they're getting the shot on camera
and during that moment you just grab
them and drop them down position to be
fair though I will die in the process
I'll bleed out but it'll be worth it and
again I want to point out self-defense
self-defense right now I think I feel
like in that scenario everyone wins you
went out epically no but he also got a
dead body in his all right he got he got
he got scars to remember me I I like
that PewDiePie grabbed him by the nuts I
mean who wouldn't be a winner in that
situation I say all right next up Shane
Dawson Dean Dawson yeah all right good
eye it begs the question how tall is
Shane Dawson I don't know I have no idea
he looks like he's at least seven foot
tall he looks so Thomas videos 183 what
is that that's like a half a dozen way
taller than me he's 510 Brett all right
okay you're so tall I did watch one
Shane Austin video where he was working
out for like 15 minutes I think that
puts him an advantage over me as well
right actually working out there that's
that takes a lot of effort I also think
Shane Dawson has secret hidden strength
inside him that will put him in an
advantage right right right been through
a lot in his lifetime he knows he has
experience yeah he has experience he's
been through it however quick that's
right I'm quick I'm drop I know Shane's
weakness I'll drop some trivia about him
yeah some trivia that is gonna blow his
mind like Shane the floor is made of
floor
Shayne will be distracted I'll go for
the I won't go for the nuts but I'll go
first I'll go for his liver go for his
liver okay yeah you tell him that and it
like starts playing like the intense
music and zooming in on his face he's
just like shaking his head like he's
drop-kicking from the side yeah yeah yes
when he least expected um I wouldn't
deliver the final blow however I'll put
him somewhere here no I think he just
needs to learn a lesson right okay yeah
I'll just do something weird like spit
in his mouth or something you gotta make
sure they didn't come at you again just
still one of his shoes or something so
he remembers he's like oh man he stole
my other shoe but spit in his mouth okay
hey shape don't ever I'll see what you
have to say about Will Smith it's new
Will Smith I forgot guy is a youtuber
now
okay well Will Smith yet he's like 500
years old dude if you still make him
youtube videos at that age I mean you
got to be strong as hell yeah yes best
Puri least well I don't even you're
strong or you're just like on the verge
of breaking down one of the two there's
no in-between they there's knowing
what's inside of Will Smith it could be
all empty in there however it makes it
even more dangerous I keep saying
however I always have a trap card all
right card oh yeah says he's so old I
can deliver the fatal insult okay boomer
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I'm sorry
defense in my hand I could see that but
anime seemed like holding her hand out
I'm like the bright light and like your
heads on the other side okay boomer so
far you you're winning all these who's
net who do you think would be a tough
fight for you
probably someone unexpected oh yeah yeah
maybe Emma Chamberlain in much amber
lamb first of all whamon I cannot hurt
give advantage how 2019 of you that's
right I'm disappointed already I can see
the write-up post already I haven't done
anything bad oh yeah but you won't
because she's winning
mm-hmm you got it you got it you gotta
exercise that that gender equality smack
her down all right okay fine yeah
this is self-defense okay this is why
you're my second in command Ken thank
you I'll just say what you wanted to say
so everybody can blame me for it yeah
although I feel like my Shamblin would
be the kind of person that would do
something weird that like throws you off
completely flesh hairy armpit like oh oh
what's happening and then BAM you're
dead did you dodge the flashing of the
hairy arm one second you're winning the
fight the second you've been beaten
theft by ambushed ambulance it's one of
those I don't know what it's called
let's keep ski girls I don't know what
it's called I'm a boob or help me what
are these oh yeah I don't know I'm with
dr. Bell on a November - let's just get
a bunch of people in the middle that
don't really matter that you think you
can use thumb in there you know whatever
Joel Rumi he's Swedish he's a little
shorter than me though so I think that
gives me an advantage oh yeah yeah he
knows music so maybe you can dance but
mr. beast mercy clean up mr. bean he
would just hire someone or just you know
baby way all right hit man or something
yeah he's like here he's 500 bucks one
random person who defeats PewDiePie for
me a million dollars and but all right
this abuse killed me
damn we also have jeffree star and then
we have Liza coach C mu haters I'm just
gonna put them to kill cuz I just oh and
more excel this is same time you got you
they're all that's riding around the car
and they were trying to running you over
but you jumped out the way in the last
thing
they all just like roll it up a cliff
and you win because they can't drop they
can't drop it's not my fault they can't
drive you're right
I also have another version for some
people a Trisha the car ran off a cliff
into into a volcano that's what happened
yeah the car I'm completely not
responsible but there was going to be a
pool of lava underneath don't do that to
that poor lava that by lava didn't
deserve that
poor lava I've seen the Chad for the
lava
all right so Tana and Oh actually I
think Moritz as well classifiers in this
category where they're the kind of
youtubers that they don't die like I can
try and dip them in a pit of lava they
would come back they always come back
yeah always come back so I would have to
use some sort of tactic to immobilize
them like something really bad oh you
can block them on Twitter no I meant
like hurting them physically what is
that would that would hurt them
perfectly what about their only weakness
come on Twitter James Charles you can't
handle that have you seen those pictures
I know you cheese he's probably done
5,000 squats we should press your head
in between those and you'll like it
another thing is that he knows how to
dress up as a woman which could throw
you off because I'm not supposed to hurt
women we talked about this Oh drop
Hickam Sorry Sorry
what becomes what you thought was your
strength became your weakness James ksi
oh my god how could you handle this case
I yeah he's stronger than me is he
taller than me though 183 aw come on
he's a split hair taller than me all
right fine yes the upper advantage and
he would probably kill me as well let's
get really ER however I think I see this
as another last stand situation I'm in
the fetal position I'm ready to bleed
out but I'm like milk grab his bandana
pull it up head explodes Oh
shoots him into dropping lava pool oh so
close
it was a good fight I'm not gonna lie it
was a good fight who would have thought
the bandana yeah no one thought of that
crazy
all right ninja you don't have to worry
about it you can go ahead he's already
killed himself by going to mixer oh yeah
that's me why you're my second bride you
made a gadget all right I put Jaden just
to get like more female male I'm
starting to see a trend here on uh well
there seems to be a lot of dead people
yeah that you would be you would kill
self-defense in self-defense
I would never solicit violence towards
anyone unless you put me to the edge
don't ever come at me you know over at
it bliss is oh my god this is why he I
mean it's night for water quality you
would you would you know take another
whatever thumbnails and she were just
going through lava it's getting tricky
now we have Vsauce oh he does have that
SOI boy looking face mm-hmm not enough
protein not good like puts me in an
advantage however he's got a mat vast
trivia of knowledge well why does him
like the good things about him make him
feel closer to him Dyna that's what I'm
wondering oh sorry yeah he's very smart
he just keeps going over there to his
own death I'm like oh my god I don't
want visas to beat me though help me
he's gonna forget anyway - any way to
win fine all right he'll kill me gosh
well I mean he goes in the category of
mr. B's that's fine he'll take it
you'll hear G with some theories and
some brains must be like then that
explain jacksepticeye he challenged me
on Twitter as well alright first of all
that's holy is jacksepticeye like 4 foot
8 and I'm taller that puts me in an
advantage well hold on a second you this
is like fighting yourself this is like
fighting a mirror version of you this is
green PewDiePie were talking about
how would you beat yourself I feel like
you uh how would I be myself somebody
gotta think I'm easy I feel like Jack
has a lot of hidden strengths though
well he's a drummer you know so he's got
that that arm strength he does have arm
strength
yeah and he's Irish that means that I
don't take a lot of punches that's right
yeah yeah okay fine
but he wouldn't kill me Jack would never
hurt me or maybe those scenarios where
you think Jack would never hurt me but
once you're hanging on that Cliff on the
pool of lava he looks down at you and
say it's my time now I would want to
fight you though he'd want to get along
with you you know he is nice put them in
the middle you guess start to fight but
then you just decide that it's not worth
it so you guys kiss and make up
mark pryor Oh Rose hope or hos alright
markiplier this is a tough one
he is extremely short with them
extremely large head though so it's an
easy target for you there's a big hitbox
he's dead already
yeah yeah like maybe in real life mark
probably actually beat you but I don't
know that's why you're here to confirm
and yeah right of course you would win
easy all right so next we have Petey pie
oh here we definitely kicked my ass we
look at that beard I could he fight that
if there was a clone of me I've
definitely killed a clone that can only
be won
well well well can it seems like it's
only you and me land yeah like this
anything but this we're friends okay
a lot of people suffer today a lot of
people died if we don't go through with
it
it would all be for nothing you're right
only one of us can survive only one of
us can go on no comeback I'm here to
preach one thing and one thing only to
PewDiePie
okay damn that's hugs not drugs give me
a hug okay here's your beta finally
after all the years top of the food
chain I did it I did it I was gonna
backstab you you got me first all right
there you have it folks
a lot of damn thanks for watching thank
you Ken for being my second yeah if you
haven't checked that Cass travels by now
I mean I don't know what to tell you
it's been years I mean case alright
thanks for watching bye bye hey dope
we're all excited about the new game
that's coming out and I can't wait to
play it it starts with the letter P can
you guess what it is
here with E PI pick selling of course
what you thought it was Pokemon dumbass
you stinky brainer
you